between Ghostbusters phase Falls and
Honey I Shrunk the Kids Rick Moranis
earned his status as one of the great
comedy icons of the 80s
sadly the actor has since stepped away
from the camera leaving us to wonder
exactly what happened here's what we
know about Rick Moranis leaving
Hollywood in his own words family man
Miranda stopped appearing in live-action
movies after his wife Ann died of breast
cancer in 1997 immediately after he
shifted his focus to raising their two
children and the rare interviews he's
given over the years since her passing
Moranis has remained nonchalant about
his decision to become a stay-at-home
dad in 2015 he told The Hollywood
Reporter I took a break which turned
into a longer break fiercely protective
of his children he won't even reveal
their names to the press it's not
unusual these days giving up a
multi-million dollar movie career at its
peak might seem like a crazy idea but
when he made his decision to leave
Hollywood Moranis didn't think he was
doing anything out of the norm he told
the podcast bullseye with Jesse thorn
stuff happens to people every day and
they make adjustments in their lives for
all kinds of reasons and there was
nothing unusual about what happened or
or what I did in fact Moranis believes
people only paid attention at the time
because he was walking away from money
and fame because I came from celebrity
and fame and what and what was a peak of
a career that was intriguing to people
and to me it wasn't that it wasn't
anything to do with that it was just
work and it was time to make an
adjustment missing the action Marianas
described a lot of sameness when it came
to raising kids so he admitted to
bullseye that there were certain parts
about acting that he did actually miss I
missed the people and I missed the the
very refreshing nature of doing
something radically different every day
still he didn't look back with any
regrets he said later to The Hollywood
Reporter I found lots of joy and lots of
rewards and other places I was working
with really interesting people wonderful
people I want
not to being at home with a couple of
little kids which is a very different
lifestyle but it was important to me I
have absolutely no regrets whatsoever my
life is wonderful don't call it a
comeback contrary to many reports
Moranis maintains that he never actually
retired from show business case in point
he's done a ton of voice work over the
years including radio commercials and
Disney's Brother Bear film series he's
also done some op-ed contributing for
the New York Times so if you want to
know how many sinks he has you're in
luck
spoiler alert it's five Miranda says
also released two albums over 10 years
the first the agoraphobic cowboy earned
him a Grammy nomination for best comedy
album the second my mother's brisket and
other love songs hit stores in 2013 in
other words he's totally still around
you just have to listen more carefully
all in good time
naturally when a star as big as
Miranda's takes a break from making
movies the question is going to come up
when will he be back
for years Miranda's dodged that question
often implying that acting just wasn't
on his radar in 2006 he told the USA
Today I'm a single parent and I just
found that it was too difficult to
manage raising my kids and doing the
traveling involved in making movies I
found that I really didn't miss it in
the last few years I've been offered a
number of parts and movies and I've just
turned them down I don't know whether
I'll go back to it or not however in
2015 Miranda's admitted to The Hollywood
Reporter that he's potentially
interested in pursuing live-action roles
in the future it's just going to have to
be the right one saying I still get the
occasional query about a film or
television role and as soon as one comes
along and that piques my interest I'll
probably do it I'm happy with the things
I said yes to and I'm very happy with
the many things I've said no to yes I am
picky and I'll continue to be picky
picky has worked for me who you gonna
call
Paul FIGS much-anticipated Ghostbusters
reboot is among the many scripts that
have come to Miranda's over the years
despite the cameos from Bill Murray dan
Aykroyd and Sigourney Weaver marina's
turned the project down the reason it
didn't appeal to him he told The
Hollywood Reporter I wish them well I
hope it's terrific but it just makes no
sense to me
why would I do just one day of shooting
on something I did 30 years ago fair
enough but we're still pretty bummed he
said no
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know your favorite
Rick Moranis role